So have you guys have requested faster,
make a video about France now Francis,
one of the wealthiest countries in the
welds.
Yes.
One with some of the artists,
economic problems today.
France is the second largest economic
power in the European Union bus that
might not last for much longer.
They youth unemployment rate is over 23
percent in their public debt is twice as
big as that entire GDP.
Ten years ago,
the entire world was buying Renno cars
or Alcatel mobile phones,
but today French experts of almonds are
half of what they used to be just a
short time ago.
Their companies are simply unable to
face the competition that's coming from
China,
from South Korea,
rob,
even from the United States in general.
And as you can imagine,
this economic crisis has had a great
effect on French society.
If you don't believe me,
let's just have a look at the
presidential elections of this year.
That's 2017.
None of the candidates from the
traditional parties have made it to the
second rounds.
French voters are simply fed up with
their political establishment,
and this is why they've chosen a
politician who wants to make a one 80
shift in the French
system.
You might be wondering what are the
reasons behind this French crisis and
more importantly,
what is macron propose in order to solve
it all today,
we're going to answer that question,
but before we get started,
as usual,
let's take a look at the history,
right
is to the French people.
Right after World War Two,
all the European powers were on the
verge of bankruptcy men.
This included France,
half the country was destroyed by
bombing and this included houses as well
as factories.
Luckily enough though,
Uncle Sam was there and then he was
ready to
hell no
states was interested in having a strong
Europe say that the consonants could
purchase goods from them.
This lead duty,
so called Marshall Plan being put into
place.
It was a cash injection of billions of
dollars,
which would lead to the reconstruction
of the European nations,
but do hold on just a minute because
each of these countries use the finance
in very different ways.
For instance,
the German government created that
political theory called auto liberalism,
a gay social liberalism.
This was a combination of social
programs and free enterprise.
In other words,
the government would provide a safety
net for their citizens and subsidize the
companies as well,
but on the other hand is these companies
were privates as they could compete with
them.
A very,
very different case.
Back then,
the president was general Charles de
Gaulle,
and he was no friend of free enterprise,
so his political theory,
Deer Ridge Ism was pretty different from
that of the gym.
His cabinet
is not giving proposals,
but to give so used all of this money
from the United States do nationalize
the big corporations,
steel factories,
electric companies,
phone companies,
even the car making them off like Renno
and citron.
They all had the government as their
biggest shareholder,
but not only that,
they also created a deregister system on
society where the state would play a
major role in all areas,
including conditions for hiring workers
as well as the minimum wage.
This is a really important point because
not all welfare states that created the
same in Germany.
There was no minimum wage and there was
a bigger space for trade unions and
companies do negotiate contract
conditions.
Further,
healthcare was provided by private
insurance and regional governments has a
lot to say when it came to the laws and
regulations.
Nevertheless,
in France,
all of the social policies came from the
central authority,
in other words,
to go represents kind of the opposite of
what we like era,
visual,
holistic,
but despite all of that,
during these first few years after World
War Two from center to these so called
glorious 30 for three decades,
the average wage triples and those
companies sponsored by the governments
became a global leader.
Give some context.
This was way before American companies
started moving their factories to China.
Renu initial inward opening factories in
Spain where salaries were much lower,
but let's be honest,
during that time,
every European country was growing at
the same rate.
Just think about it.
We're talking about the 19 sixties.
That was not the economic powerhouse
that it is today.
Latin America was full of dictatorships
of all kinds,
and the Soviet Union was simply unable
to produce high enough quality goods to
be sold in the international market.
Nonetheless,
France had unimportant industrial
tradition.
They've had a well educated society,
and overall it had good rule of law and
stable political system
companies.
Not only that,
in 1958,
so those countries already rebuilds by
the Marshall Plan,
decided to create a free trade union
which would eventually become the
European Union.
At this time,
if France had the largest population of
these countries,
and I don't forget the back in that
time,
Germany was still divided into two hops.
All of this meant that France was in the
strongest position.
Do you negotiate that entry conditions?
And as I said before,
Charles,
the goal was no fan of free trade.
He used his negotiating how to make
France the dominant country in certain
industries such as aggregate
culture,
Europe,
Europe.
It doesn't help anything nor means
anything.
So if you are watching this video from
anywhere in Europe,
you might have heard about the common
agricultural policy.
This is a policy created to keep
European consumers from buying
agricultural goods from the developing
world,
but not only that,
it also imposes production quotas inside
of the European economic area.
This means Polish or Spanish.
Farmers cannot sell enough that they
want to sell.
There is a maximum quota imposed by
Brussels and you can probably guess
that,
Oh yes,
this was a French invention.
It helps explain things like,
yes,
price value of 70 point 4 billion euros
in 2011.
French agricultural production is the
leader in Europe.
The goal held power for decades and the
following French presidents kept this
dirigiste model at the end of the day,
during the 19 sixties and seventies,
France was on fire,
so if something works,
why would you fix it?
Oh,
well actually now I'm going to tell you
exactly why you should fix it,
st
to a different problem.
The problem starts when the rest of the
world is running faster than you were.
Of course.
Talking about the eighties and nineties,
the Berlin Wall came down.
China started opening up their economy
and lots of new countries like Spain and
Greece became members of the European.
Yeah,
union,
and of course all of these countries
wanted to sell their products.
In other words,
all of the sudden France had rifles,
and this is what explains why this kind
of news is quite so common,
furious French farmers who have been
attacking Spanish fruit and vegetable
deliveries has affects of the e coli
crisis,
continue to bite Spanish producers of
slash their prices to make up for huge
losses and now up to forty cents a kilo
cheaper than their French counterparts.
The same happens with other industries.
Take a look at this chart that
represents the trade balance in France.
Pay Attention.
You can see how often the nineties
exports on dropping slowly.
This trend is especially true after the
financial crisis,
so maybe you under the Alcatel mobile
phones,
these were mobile phones that were
really popular when mobile phones were
just becoming a thing.
Alcatel was an absolute juggernaut in
this area and now they've said
disappeared in a market dominated by
American Chinese and South Korean
companies,
and this is just one example of how
France is losing their ability to
innovative.
Now you might be wondering what of all
the French government's done to tackle
this problem?
Well,
really they just protected the companies
from the rest of the welds.
For an opposite example,
let's have a look at Sweden.
He makes Volvo cars where the Chinese
company wanted to buy this from.
The Swedish government didn't intervene
at all in Sweden.
There was a clear separation between
business and the state,
but we cannot say the same of France.
Just have a look at what happens when it
Pepsi wanted to buy the new moon in 2000
and
fine
barlow.
The labor minister said the government
will do all we can to oppose a bid and
Terry Britain,
the finance minister,
pledge to protect Donald,
but this is not the only thing that
doesn't change.
In France.
They're social spending is still the
highest in the European Union.
Even larger than that of the Nordic
countries and further the French
administration employees,
more civil sevens than any other
European country and their salaries are
also pretty enormous.
So basically France has a lower income
than they had in the past,
but they keep spending like they did
during the glory days.
This explains why their public debt is
quite as large as it is,
what things they might just be on the
verge of change.
Crones,
quiet revolution.
Alright,
so politicians do you promise a lot
during elections and they don't do
always deliver on those promises,
but there is something we have to admit.
In the case of Kronk,
his program is a complete break with the
French dirigisme.
All the political analysts have labeled
this man,
is it motor a politician?
He wants to continue the work of his
predecessors,
but the big question is,
is that really true?
The truth is that some of his proposals,
they've never even been put forward by
another French presidents from any side
of the political spectrum is precisely a
big reform program to open up a series
of services and increased competition in
terms of products.
And good markets,
transportation on some for the better
understanding in an electoral campaign
that became famous because of the
populous tone of Mrs [inaudible],
Mr Macron is proposing to retire over
120,000 civil sevens know many of you
might think that this is a pretty
horrible idea,
but there is something we must admit
he's being on it.
Yes.
No,
the politician who would suggest such an
unpopular thing during an election.
Nonetheless,
macron has won this election by often
doing the opposite of what a candidate
should supposedly do.
On his manifesto,
he promised that he would never reduce
the return and sage and other words,
macron is really committed to reducing
French publix
ending
on the other hands.
Macron combines all of these budget cuts
with lowering taxes and helping small
companies in his own words.
Macron wants to substitute the French
dirigisme with something closer to the
model of Germany or Sweden where welfare
states coexist with the free market
economy.
So now you might be wondering,
even after winning the elections,
does he have any actual power to make
this happen?
In France?
The president doesn't have as much power
as the American president sends.
Every lawyer wants to pass,
has to go through parliaments and now
the question has to be who is the
biggest force in parliaments weld.
That is something we're not going to
know until the summer of 2017 in June.
French people are going to go back to
the voting stations and this time
they're voting and legislative elections
and it is here that the party of Marine
Le Pen,
the national front,
has a better chance of becoming the main
four.
What does the French for our rights
actually want?
Well,
if you'd like to know more about that,
you should definitely check out one of
our previous videos,
which you can click on,
right?
Yeah.
And now the question is,
do you really believe in this quiet
revolution of Emmanuel Macron?
Do you believe that he can pull from
sound of the whole?
Do you think French stagnation has a
solution?
Well,
the comments below,
we'd love to hear and don't forget,
we've published brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday,
so don't forget to hit that subscribe
button so you won't miss any posts.
And if you like this video,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
And I'd also like to thank for you
reconsider video podcasts for providing
the voice of the vocals for this
episode.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next year.
Right.